let's look at the solution with our storage comparison quiz. The total access
time with the disk will be when we play a game, we will read two gigabytes
at 100 megabytes a second, so we will spend 20 seconds reading
these two gigabytes. And we will also spend ten
seconds writing to the ten megabytes. So we will spend 30 seconds
here and then a sequential read of the
one gigabyte here will be another ten seconds.
So over the four hours we spent 40
seconds reading and writing you, using the disk, we
repeat that four times. And we get 40
seconds times four, equals 160 seconds. With flash, we
get one gigabyte per second so we will
get two seconds and change and another one second.
So we will get 3.01 seconds times 4. We get 12.04 seconds. Which is way better
than the disk. But if all we have is flash, we have to buy a lot of flash,
and we probably paid thousands of dollars. So,
now let's say what happens with the disk and
the four gigabytes of flash. The first time
we read these two gigabytes and another ten megabytes,
we will read them in 30 seconds, because we are accessing our disk, but then we
move them to the flash. The next read is going to be the one gigabyte again in
ten seconds but we move them to the flash. So we spend 40 seconds accessing
the disk in the first round of this, and we spend 3.01 seconds
copying this data to the flash. After that, we're having
the flash access time. So all together we have 40 seconds of disk access
time, plus 1 4th of this for copying to the flash, and 3 4ths of this for
actually reading off the flash the same as
here, for a total of 52.04 seconds. So
although it's slower than pure flash, it's still
much faster than pure disk. And this is
about as costly as a single disk, because four
gigabytes of flash are not going to cost us that much.